yes citizens of the reject Nation it's
me Tara Erikson and I don't know why I
have a terrible exent that was awesome
this is my H John
um hrey hey you got there I did it you
got there how are you John I'm good I'm
wishing I had a better Ryan Reynolds
impression for you pretty good I can do
it sometimes it'll get better as the
movie goes okay all right I'd like to
see it who here has like a lowkey
obsession with Ryan Reynolds cuz me a
little bit but it's from my show Welcome
to reom and you guys if you don't know
about it what's your favorite Ryan
Reynolds joint exactly you got to write
it down right now me currently my
favorite Ron reynoldson is welcome to
rexim thanks for pre for helping us edit
down these videos also you get super sex
you got to get on the patreon you can
sink up with your own copy and watch
most of all of The Proposal with me and
John also Greg and John offer exclusive
highlights and watch alongs over there
on patreon so if you go over there you
get sexy but not just like sexy he's
like super sexy like you see how he
touch his butt and it burns it's burning
with
SE okay are we ready to watch it almost
but you missed the most important iconic
part of the intro you got to leave a
like more important than leaving a like
is the part were you ring the
bell ring the bell you guys how did I
forget that guys I'm not being true to
myself but thank God I in Christmas gear
and oh my God Santa I know him I know
I'm killing John's ears and I'm killing
you guys but we're going to get into
we're going to watch the proposal and
get this three longest intro ever two
one
ooh I like this song I'm in it I'm in it
let's get it oh it's like a really
lowkey version of the evil
Deadshot wait now what movie is that oh
this song will get you going yeah man oh
plus what a great setup she can bike in
the city and in the woods all at the
same time Molen aeran Ah that's craigy
Nelson you needed set that clock
though oh Betty White get out of town
you're my golden girl
Tera here you go your regular lattes
literally saved my life thank you thank
hey oh she like is this free guy right
now maybe he wants a cappuccino
maybe he found his way he did it was a
very very you know portentous song yeah
close one of those mornings thank you
Captain Obvious
oh
Jesus whoa dude that was so loud yeah
little pent up this morning don't don't
talk to you to you've had your coffee
trick that thing down leave the shirt
off your back literally you're kidding
right Yankees Boston this Tuesday two
company seats for your shirt you have 5
Seconds to decide 5 4 3 2 1 so quick
quick
countdown uh-oh everybody
oh it's she's she's called an it that
means she's a
monster oh oh my God uh oh I'm terrified
too although she does look very good
morning boss you have conference call in
30 minutes yes about the marketing of
the spring books I know did you call
them what's her name the one the one
with the the ugly hands oh my your
immigration lawyer called he said that
it's imperative he cancel the call Push
the meeting to tomorrow and keep the
lawyer on the sheets oh and get a hold
of PR and have them start drafting a
press release Frank is doing Oprah
wow okay Queen who is Jillian and why
does she want me to call
her a so cute well that was originally
my cup and I'm drinking your coffee why
because your coffee spilled oh no murder
him stab him in the gut so you drink
unsweetened cinnamon light soy lattes I
do it's like Christmas in a cup sounds
delicious and you would know I would I'm
like Christmas in a
cup why are we headed to Bob's office
uh oh
[Laughter]
boy God this office chat whoa have you
finished the manuscript I gave you I
read a few pages that wasn't on
impressed ouch man I've read thousands
of manuscripts and this is the only one
I've ever given you there's an
incredible novel in there the kind of
Novel you used to publish uh wrong oh no
and I do think you order the same coffee
as I do just in case you spill which is
in fact pathetic how many days has he
not spilled it though yeah give him a
little credit witchy fearless leader and
her Le please do come in hey a man is it
new it is English Regency Egyptian
Revival built in the 1800s but yes it is
new to my
[Music]
office I like the way you think I'm
letting you go no no why he just got a a
hutch thing asked you over a dozen times
to get Frank to do Oprah and you didn't
do it a lot of times I have told you
that is impossible Frank hasn't done an
interview in 20 years well that is
interesting because I just got off the
phone with him and he is in oh bad I
will give you 2 months to find another
job and then you can tell everyone you
resign okay ouch okay well at least
she's kind of nice about that a little
you poisonous you can't fire me oh
fire me you are threatened by me Po stop
just because you have no semblance of a
life oh uhoh that you can treat all of
us like your own personal slaves you
know what I feel sorry for you mans is
living the dream he's really getting in
there listen carefully Bob I didn't fire
you because I feel threatened I fired
you because you're lazy entitled
incompetent and you spend more time
cheating on your wife than you do in
your office oo you are going out of here
with an armed escort Andrew will film it
with this little camera phone and he
will put it on that internet site was it
YouTube exactly oh it's this is that old
we don't know about YouTube yeah come on
or at least put on e-bombs world this
weekend to help review his files in his
manuscripts this weekend you have a
problem with that no I I just my
grandmother's not this weekend Grandma
listen I've worked too hard for this
promotion to throw it all away okay I'm
sure the dad is pissed but we take all
of our submissions around here very
seriously and we'll get back to you as
soon as we
can is that your family yes they tell
you to quit every single
day oh yeah okay or going I want to see
upstairs immediately come get me in 10
minutes we've got a lot to doie do
stressful poor Ryan Reynold Ryan
Reynolds working for the weekend
Margaret do you remember when we agreed
that you wouldn't go to the Frankfurt
book fair because you weren't allowed
out of the country while your visa
application was being processed yes I
did she Canadian your visa application
has been denied that that and you are
being deported whoa what oh come on it's
it's not like I'm even an immigrant
you've been pushing that meeting girl
I'm from Canada for Christ's sake there
got to be something we can do she's
Canadian can't nice your way out of this
one unfortunately you have to leave the
country for at least a year
okay this is guitar tones until this is
resolved I'm going to turn operations
over to Bob's faing the guy I just
fired if there was any way we could make
this thing work we'd be doing it there
is no way I I oh no oh there is what
what Mary from Miss Winfrey's office
called I told her you were otherwise
engaged she
insisted Mary all these
words oh no
uhoh oh we were getting right to it oh
all right well I think there's something
that you should
know H oh my goodness we're uh we're
getting married a with a pat we are
getting married we getting married yes
is it he your secretary assistant
executive assistant
secretary promoted demoted and repromed
all in one conversation you know Andrew
and I were we are just two people who
weren't meant to fall in love but we did
did face so dear in the oh my God can't
can't fight a can't can't fight a can't
fight a love like
ours
that's good such great subtle physical
comy yeah it's so good just make it
legal
oh thank you very much gentlemen we will
do that right away thank you very much
gentlemen thank you gentlemen gentlemen
who is the gentleman behind the desk he
looks so familiar oh yeah he works like
a ton uh I don't understand what's
happening they were going to make Bob
Chief so naturally I would have to marry
you I'm not going to marry you you sure
you are because if you don't marry me
your dreams of touching the lives of
Millions with the written word are
dead yikes can't work for an American
company but I can torpedo you but don't
worry after the required allotment of
time we'll get a quicky divorce and be
done with me but until then like it or
Not Your Wagon is hitched to mine okay
although there is something very very
appealing about her sense of authority
that witch bro man
yes cadabra
baby are you both committing fraud to
avoid her deportation so she can keep
her position as editor and chief at Cen
books excellent deductive reasoning sir
let me explain to you the process that's
about to unfold step one I'll put you
each in a room and I'll ask you every
little question a real couple would know
about each other oh my you young man
will have committed a felony punishment
by a fine of
$250,000 and a stay of 5 years oh my
good Federal Prison
what they're both beautiful just let
them get married it's the way the worlds
just do it the truth is Margaret and I
are just two people who weren't supposed
to fall in love but did see knows the
value of a good call back good Motif we
couldn't tell anyone we worked with
because of my my big promotion that I
had coming up promotion yes we both felt
uh that it would be uh deeply
inappropriate if I were to be promoted
to editor while we were yeah have the
two of you told your parents about your
secret love impossible my parents are
dead no brothers or sisters either hey
that's like me hey dude you're Sandy B I
am what are your parents dead no his his
are very much alive you're going to tell
them this weekend G's 90th birthday you
thought it'd be a nice surprise and
where is this surprise going to take
place Sitka Sitka Alaska Alaska yes I
will see you both at 11:00 Monday
warning for your scheduled interview and
your answers better match up whenever
you count W oh thing you said about
being promoted genius I was serious I'm
looking at a $250,000 fine in 5 years in
jail that changes things y yeah it does
no then I quit and you're screwed
bye-bye Margaret really has been a
little slice Andrew Andrew fine wow fine
and you'll publish my manuscript yes
yeah you tell give me a cocktail napkin
and a pen yeah now ask me nicely to
marry you get down on one knee what does
that mean you heard me on your knee
yes oh my gosh no
way
yes like a gentleman oh my oh but that
skirt yeah it would be hard yeah say it
like you mean it yes
daddy sweet Andrew would you please put
Cher Eyes On Top Mar
me okay I don't appreciate the sarcasm
but I'll do it the airport
tomorrow
oh buddy sick burn I love their yeah
like the way their power Dynamic is
Shifting and and the way they're really
not relying on suspension of disbelief
to sell this like it's so great
everything is like no these are the
obstacles good news is is I know
everything about you but the bad news is
that you have 4 days to learn all this
about me so I should probably get
studying do you even care enough to
learn what am I allergic to pine nuts in
the full spectrum of human
emotion do I have any scars I'm pretty
sure that you have a tattoo 2 years ago
your dermatologist called and asked
about a q switch laser and found that
they in fact do remove tattoos so what
is it Japanese calligraphy barire yes
whose Place do we stay at yours or mine
that's easy mine and why wouldn't we
stay at mine uh because I live at
Central Park West oh and you probably
live at some squalid little Studio Park
with stacks of yellow penguin
classic rude don't knock my penguin
classics all right yellow is personality
I
[Music]
agree is that his mom hey oh love her of
course that would have to be gram gam
gam would have to be Betty W his mom
plays the mom in all romcoms in the 9s
yes like she is the mom in elf she's the
mom in oh what other God she plays mom
in like Mary steam bgin is America's mom
yes she
[Music]
is O Bill Paxton okay a lot of Paxton
this is the person she needs to find and
beat down in front of everyone to
establish dominance
agreed it's him oh my God he's a Paxton
you didn't tell me about all the family
businesses honey probably just being
modest dear oh do we just own the town
yeah like the whole saying we just own
new Asgard over here look deep into my
eyes shouldn't we check into our hotel
right now family doesn't stay at a hotel
you're going to stay in our home great
oh God you want to use your legs to lift
that
one help her with those i' would love to
she won't let me do anything insists on
doing it all herself she one those uh
she's
feminist she's a girl boss at the very
least this is the last of
them oh my God
it's Louis vuon Louis V I'm not getting
on that boat you don't have to see in a
few days you know I can't swim hence the
boat looking good boss
she she's going to
fall yeah into his arms
[Music]
a she he's in a light jacket guys you
got to learn how to swim let me just
just learn how to swim Primal skill the
thing you should have on a 70 to 80%
water Planet yeah you got to know we are
wa she's like wow I had no
idea who are you people you thought so
little of him and look at him in his big
mansion now yeah I wonder what this
movie would be like if it was just like
a modest studio apartment right or like
a regular family home in a sub would
work for a romcom one of them always has
to be loaded that's true you never told
me you were rich I'm not rich my parents
are rich you know what that's something
only rich people
say that's fair people need to think
that we are in love so it's just that
that's no problem I can do that I can
pretend to be the the doting fiance that
that's easy you know but for you it's
it's going to require that you stop
snacking on children while they
dream
Margaret hi pleasure so I always wanted
to know what does a book editor do
that's a great question Louise oh oh my
gosh coach America's Dad look at him why
don't you tell us exactly what a book
editor does I mean besides taking
writers out to lunch and getting bombed
h no wonder do you like being an editor
no no Andre is not an editor he's an
editor's assistant Maggie here is the
editor oh all right Dad slow it down
what's your game you show up here here
after all this time with this woman you
hated and now she's your girlfriend we
just got here can we wait 2 seconds
before we throw the kitchen sink at each
other just never figured you for a guy
who slipped his way to the
middle ouch she's my fiance getting
married oo okay hey hey look at him
what's up that tradition oh but see it's
the the texture I'm not a a fish person
you're very very sweet I think you oh oh
right in the hole
there to make Margaret and I are getting
married
yeah come on down here pumpkin pumpkin
pump come on
pumpkin brilliant brilliant time Andrew
uhoh oh is that his a hey hi wow and
we're being completely rude hi oh did I
miss the story about how you proposed oh
how a man proposes says a lot about his
character H Andrew and I were about to
celebrate our first anniversary together
and I knew that he'd been itching to ask
me to marry him oh boy oh boy that's not
exactly how it happened no
no the game is a foot she might find
this little box oh the decopage box that
he
made tiny little pictures of himself yes
just past it all over the box so
beautiful I miss decupage yeah but
inside that box with the address to a
hotel date and time real Humphrey Bogart
type stuff yeah Bogart there he was
standing kneeling like a on a bed of
rose petals in a tuxedo and he was
choking back soft soft SBS oh my God and
when he held back the tears and finally
caught his breath he said to me Margaret
will you marry me and she said yep yep
hey let's see a
kiss I can see how she's an editor I
could see it yeah she can she can weave
a yarn she can do it
ready is this on
the Jesus man the best Winger
wingman
oh Andy a real
kiss a real
one one give us what we want just do
it MH oh kind of like it this is your
bedroom wow this is um beautiful The
View and here's the bed thank you here's
the bed oh my God it's so cute you are
cute what a little puppy just rescued
him from the pound and he's still in
training sorry just be sure you don't
let him outside the Eagles will snatch
him oh oh no good night every everybody
good night good night America's
mom you don't have a sleep mask yeah
right you seem like a sleep mask type of
person for sure yeah I agree and
earplugs too yes and a white noise
machine and a humidifier a whole thing I
mean she had like a whole screen of like
the woods to cycle with
yeah hey oh look at that and now we're
ready for the
purge Andrew come business is calling uh
oh where is
[Laughter]
it Frank Frank darling you there hello
hello I have horrible service Frank give
me just just one minute oh my God
Margaret Jesus she's probably never
sounded like this over the phone
before Oh sweet puppy dog cutest dog
I've ever seen the Eagles I love
listening to you Frank shh
sit good boy a good boy no no not you
Frank no no you don't sit Frank Frank no
not the eagle the eagle will eat him
they are just so rich with we should all
be privy to and Frank I just uh I just I
just want you to be happy give me
that
not the puppy let the puppy go holy
they really did
it oh my gosh I was so worried for the
puppy this movie wastes no time with
anything it really doesn't and and call
me tomorrow with your decision and my
phone is oh my goodness
no oh love it no no take the
oh jeez no not the
doggy take the dog take the do PI it Pi
it it a weaken
barter we can work this out we thought
she didn't like him will you go get her
Andy we have a whole day planned for it
yeah tell her we have a big surprise for
her uhoh I like surprises okay that
Eagle's going to like swallow her phone
yeah you drunk no I'm serious he's got
my phone and Frank's calling me on that
phone relax
right we'll order another phone same
number we'll go into town tomorrow and
we'll get it really yeah I guess you can
do that he solves problems where are we
with SIM cards how you're going out with
Mom and the girls I don't want to go
shopping sightseeing and a
surprise give me a nice big hug we don't
think we're
fighting I don't want I don't want to oh
there we go yeah you were the one who
said we got to sell this start selling
lady yeah you want to see me apparently
I wasn't the most gracious of hosts last
night was a little bit of a shock to
find out that you're getting married I
owe you an apology you're a good guy D I
done a lot of things in my life
practically built an Empire with your
mother from the ground up it doesn't
mean anything have someone to leave it
to yeah we've already discuss this yeah
I'd like to discuss it again oh yikes
you have responsibilities here but he
wants to write stories I need you to
quit playing around here we go again
when are you going to start taking what
I do seriously yeah yeah I wish you had
another son I really do one who wanted
to stay here one who wanted to take over
the family business one who wanted to
marry someone that you approve of but
it's not me now ouch it must seem
strange to you my life in New York
sitting in an office reading books but
it makes me happy I love books know if
that's what makes you happy son I got
nothing to say then why the hell are you
so sad yeah apology not
accepted your son isn't you sir he's his
own man
yeah have another son yeah man just find
somebody else yeah thrust your Empire
and your legacy upon that child I agree
I I hope you are ready for your big
surprise because this is one of sika's
greatest treasures right oh yeah oh is
it a
stripper with like a moose head or
something what is this oh does she have
to oh it's okay you're going to love it
oh yeah
is it who's going to be who's it going
to be who's it going to be hey my
man this is just like when Buzz on psych
was also a stripper this is
perfect don't do it when you want to go
to it relax Mo's the only exotic dancer
on the island but we're lucky to get
that Michael Jackson leg in
there don't do it
over here I made $20 stripping once wow
John yeah yeah it's crazy oh my goodness
true story for another day Tera Ericson
John's a stripper and we didn't know
it okay pluck my eyes out okay all right
oh bachelor party have a little fun yeah
it to
Ramon Ramon let's go my man
big
respect yes
sir he's going for it and I respect it
this is great I respect it never be able
to watch office reruns the same way
again
nope oh my gosh keep keep it in your
mouth man smack his ass smack his
ass yeah time it
right come on you can do it
[Music]
no no no no hey there you are the pxs
can be a bit overwhelming at times you
guys are pretty serious huh well I mean
we dated in high school and all through
college but we were kids oh oh boy
that's almost a decade that's a long
time you're a lucky girl he really is
the best
a well cheers to you
guys cheers that's so nice cheers to you
guys cheers to you guys so sweet oh no
uh oh
what oh oh no what's going on here oh
yeah letting some inner rage out I've
always dreamed of doing this bad convo
with a dad so let's he you've dreamt of
axing a log to make a boat yes exactly
exactly it's channeling your rage into
something constructive yes I would love
to go to a rage room yes oh hey I have
never
what did you do I didn't do anything I
mean I just had a a Frank conversation
with him about his future yep I only get
to see him every 3 years because of you
I've had enough you are going to be
supportive of
him that's a sign you are going to fix
this Joe I mean it fix it now fix it Joe
yeah she just took the pants the family
pants with her
mhm oh no mad cap naked
scene oh and he's going to get in with
the fog he won't be able to see oh no
this all they have for a towel it's a
my oh my goodness my
goodness I'm sorry let me just let me
just get Sandy be Sandy buns Sandy
Cheeks looking
good oh look who else is
working oh hello this movie is for
everybody it really
is H truly is a feminist Fil A doggy
he's so cute a little budy you're only
going to make my fur fluffier and more
adorable he is so cute you like it get a
pick of it for like a calendar yes show
the
world
that's a good boy yes that's good boy
come
[Applause]
on oh yeah oh
golly they're making it on top of why
are you why are
you oh my
good why are you wet why are you
atet jump me out of nowhere what's that
I didn't I didn't didn't mean to jump
you your dog was attacking me and I died
to run and I ran into you what is it
with you and this
dog nice tattoo by the way
what oh you see that barely made it out
with my life there yes this is so
great what's the deal with you and your
father oh I'm sorry that question is not
in the binder they give you specific
questions to study for but if the guy
asked about that Margaret good
night just tell her open your heart come
on man I like the Psychic Network I took
disco lessons in the sixth grade my
first concert was Rob Bas and DJ easy
rock don't like flowers in the house cuz
they remind me of funerals never played
a video game wow started
twitch haven't slept with a man in over
a year and a half oh
I thought it would be longer yeah I went
to the bathroom and cried after Bob
called me a poisonous a she cried
oh in the uh bird tattoo they're
swallows has to do with their mom or
something got them when I was 16 after
my parents died I knew it yep yeah I'm
sure there's many many other things but
it's all I can come up with right now
it's great framing with him in the
negative space changing and coming
visually closer together Chang and
opening up the space in bed next
great like you could superimpose the
shots to actually match side by side
right you really haven't slept with
anyone in 18 months oh my
God yeah buddy who's Rob Base and DJ uh
easy rock yeah you know it takes to you
to make a thing go right
oh yeah yeah I know who they are I just
wanted to hear you sing
it cute Margaret you are a very very
beautiful
[Music]
woman God I can't
see that looked like a real moment oh so
cute
a that was so cute that's lovely I
really like this movie so far me too
really enjoying this breakfast the
couple Andrew Andrew Andrew Jesus
no are you wearing makeup no no of
course
not oh my God I'm sorry it's
[Music]
morning cinnamon rolls oh you shouldn't
have gone through that trouble that's oh
your family now it's no trouble oh hey
you have room for one more everyone's
having breakfast and bed oh your mother
and I have come up with a proposition
and I happen to think it's it's a
terrific idea we want to get married
here tomorrow oh my goodness oh well
you're going to get married anyway so
why don't you get married here where we
can be all together and that way Grandma
Annie can be a part of it dude it's G's
big birthday tomorrow night we we don't
want to ruin it that's you know that's
I've had 89 birthday parties I don't
need another
one would be a dream come true for me to
see my one grandchild's wedding oh my
gosh you got to give it to Betty and you
can get married like we did in the barn
it's a Paxton family tradition oh you're
Paxton now I've always wanted to get
married in a in a barn I
have we're just so
excited
EXC Grandma's always got crazy big rings
and stuff you could probably knock
somebody's lights out with one of those
when my mom finds out that this whole
thing is a sham she's going to she's
going to be crushed and my grandmother's
going to
die it's not like we're going to be
married forever be happily divorced
before you know it no but that's exactly
what he's worried about okay yeah that's
the first time right now that she's
actually look how sheate with him yeah
he's like oh all right it might be okay
get a quicky divorce we'll be fine
absolutely it's going to be fine this
little M better learn how to cook so she
can take care of her husband uh-oh just
have to focus Margaret Focus this is a
business deal just a business deal are
you there God it's me Margaret She's Got
the Love Bug oh man she got to go to the
doctor and get that extracted
immediately yeah her business it's like
a tick leads to lime
disease oh don't say lime disease we
just just watched a just watched a movie
with a weird te falling out sequence I
don't want to know
it drums is she hearing that or is this
just the music is she time traveled is
it a time travel romance too I mean it's
a popular genre of literary fiction sure
is we'd be all right if it went there
but I doubt
it oh SN it is a summon of spirits is I
Grandma
Annie I see you are a curious one come
see how I give thanks to Mother Earth is
she one of those white people who's like
168 Chaka yeah just clings to that we
must give thanks and ask that your loins
be abundantly fertile sure follow and
learn
[Music]
he come on Margaret feel the rhythm of
the drum
Wednesday Adams is just over
there louder to the window to the window
to the walls to the walls to the sweat
drip down my
balls musical touchstones are
fascinating this song must have
been very big at the time I'm assuming
it's fertility anthem of some kind Betty
White's face is so perfect shake it let
me see you get low you scared you scared
drop your ass to the floor you scared
you scared let me see you get you scared
you scared God that was all about the
yin-yang twins in high school
boy yeah your gam wanted me to chant
chant from the heart
balls you know it uh went went with the
beat your phone arrived let going go to
town and pick it up you want to come oh
yes I want to go I want to go hold on is
it uh is it okay if I I go with him
whatever you do is what shall
be I know by
KY first I thought she
disappeared thought she like vanished
like an actual witch doctor or
something oh my God it's so beautiful
now a boat together they're falling in
love every minute more how
beautiful I need a computer is
there is there a computer in this God
forsaken town is there pxton Apple Store
don't call it God forsaken you know
you're falling forward every minute God
is out
there or maybe she gets jelly yeah she's
going to go she's going to get sad so it
was nice to see gertude huh yeah she
looked really pretty today a we're going
to have to steal you away young lady oh
no no no no I'm I'm just going to no not
to worry no strippers no chanting in the
woods
promise we're going for a Manny Petty I
can't believe this is happening oh
they're going to make our wedding dress
wow love it because Annie is the best
tailor in Southeast Alaska oh damn oh
boy yeah buddy maybe a t Grandma had
some big ones n it's perfect this is how
it's meant to fit leaves a lot to the
imagination to be knocked up when I wore
this let's see if we can find
your Savage Betty way this like an
Easter egg
huh maybe they shrunk up in the cold
Alaskan Air all are good oh yeah
agreed maybe we could head down your way
for the holidays that would be nice that
would be nice or maybe we could we could
come to you too you falling in love with
Alaska Grace for God's sake we've got
work to do I know sorry go make yourself
a cup of tea I'll finish this women
their emotions am I right always
crying something turquoise one special
touch and you're ready it's been in the
family for more than 15
years it's it's beautiful but I don't
I'm not
finished my great-grandfather gave it to
my great grandmother when they got
married they were quite a scandal you
know why he was Russian and she was
clinking back then you had to get
approval from every member of the tribe
before you got married interesting well
how did they stay together then she was
a lot like you tough wouldn't take no
for an answer interesting is Betty
actually part native
American curious about this plot through
no no I want you to have it I don't want
to hear it it's grandmothers love to
give their stuff to their
grandchildren it makes us feel like
we'll still be part of your life lives
even after we're gone
no just wanted to make sure there was
enough time to get all the sewing done
don't you worry about that you're going
to be beautiful that's sweet some there
some lovely writing across this even
that story was like I forgot I was
watching like a script you know
yeah
TI
in there they go oh boy oh going for a
she's not having James Bond cruising
sequence I forgot what it was like to
have a family forgot what it felt like
to have people love you and make you
breakfast no I'm just screwing it up
you're not screwing it up I agreed to
this you were there remember yeah
they're not going to find out you know
they
find no you know my mother my God oh my
God what if Gary finds out if Gary finds
out she's going to have a
[Music]
this a great reversal oh there she goes
this is coming Pete great now now you
decide to shut up Mar no
no save her go to
her she can surely make it to the red
thing yeah come on give me your hand hey
give me your
hand oh come on give me your hand come
come on I got you I got you oh yeah
that's right she can't she can't swim
yeah that's why he like oh she could
probably yeah she's probably freaking
out come here got to get warm come
on this is a really sweet moment yeah
and like a an actual legitimate yeah
very real real moment of of bonding and
weathering something together and like
no words you could just tell she sighed
like into him and it was I got a phone
call from Mr Gilbertson here who told me
that if you were lying he would send you
to prison so I flew him up here wow dad
oh wow you're going to make a statement
admitting this marriage is a sham or
you're going to go to prison you tell
the truth you're off the hook and she is
going to go back to Canada forever
forever ever take the deal I don't think
so don't be stupid Andrew you want a
statement here's your statement I've
been working for Margaret tapate for 3
years 6 months ago we started dating we
fell in love I asked her to marry me she
said yes oh boy all right oh man and
this guy's going to be at the reception
yeah you sure about this not really I
mean I am I am very appreciative of what
you've done but I think that you do the
same for me hope everyone is decent you
need to come with me now tomorrow is
your wedding day you have to give the
baby maker a rest
tonight yes ma'am give you br a kiss
good night and if you've got your whole
lives to be together okay yeah
[Music]
a my goodness get that
Cannon
wowa wow it's so pretty that's a barn
it's beautiful yeah these Birch
fronds so
pretty a that's so
sweet
yeah
maybe they'll admit it in the vows I
think they're she's going to have to
right cuz her whole look coming down the
aisle does not she looks too
conflicted oh my
goodness oh my gosh that was great so
good do you have a
question uh no I I do have something I
need to say can it wait to after nope
nope nope nope read too many novels I
know how this works I uh I have a bit of
an announcement to make about the the
wedding uh I am a
Canadian with an expired Visa who was
about to be deported because I didn't
want to leave this wonderful country of
yours I forced Andrew here to marry me
see Andrew has always had this
extraordinary work ethic ah yeah and for
three years I watched him work hard than
anyone else at our company and I knew
that if I threatened to destroy his
career he would he would do just about
anything real simp that Andrew so I
blackmailed him to come up here and to
lie to you and I thought it would be
easy to watch him do it jeez man turns
out it's not easy to ruin someone's life
once you find out how wonderful they are
a that's so sweet yeah you have a
beautiful family don't let this come
between you a
this was a business deal and you held up
your end but now the deal is
off
wow well done you meet me at the dock
you're giving me a ride to the airport
yes ma'am all
[Laughter]
right oh my god dude come on no
chill just get let me get my head on
straight okay I'll explain everything
late go to her
yeah going to do the run the ROM come
run to the
airport run Ryan
run oh did she leave a
note
oh oh I did some coverage of your work
you were right this book is special I
lied because I knew publishing meant I'd
lose you as an assistant but you have an
extraordinary eye and I'll make sure we
buy this before I leave a that was uh
crazy you know people are going to be
talking about this forever yeah yep it's
going to be part of my life now I just
feel you know what the problem is you
see the problem is that this woman is a
gigantic pain in my
ass I first there's the whole leaving
thing I totally understand that you know
it's a sham wedding I love the music cue
right here it's great she goes ahead and
she leaves this
note
three years I work with this this
terrorist but none of that matters
because we had a deal Andrew sorry
you're bargaining with yourself Andrew
so you're just going to let her go no
you're not oh swim to her yeah go in
that speed boat you own call aquam man
do some meta and get out there man
you got this now that you're leaving
voluntarily It all becomes very
civilized you have 24 hours to head back
to Canada dude is it just for the year
thing or do you do you have to go
forever now yeah I wonder Andrew Andrew
what's I got to talk to her why would
you do that says nothing to do is wait a
minute I'm not going to let you do this
I mean it I'm not asking the permission
here listen to she's going to have
a somebody get a doctor easy oh no
no dang oh it's like in Moon struck
where it's like the mom is either dying
or not dying depending on if the the
who's marrying the right person
oh speak to us Betty yeah tell him you
two need to stop fighting no you'll
never see eye to eye your family promise
me a you'll stand by Andrew even if you
don't agree with this family business
not business Family Promise me you work
work harder to be a part of this
family the spirits can take me no it's
not your time
no she joking I guess they not ready for
me oh my goodness oh my goodness I love
it a on well was the only way I could
get you two to shut up and get us to the
airport
love it she's a good one yeah you made
me cry it's messed up Betty White up
back in New York I'm like Elliot in this
always get my man dude not now Bo this
guy is a lot now man he's too much1 as
soon as you're in position you're this
guy it's his boy yeah it's his friend
it's going to it's going to come in
handy he's going to cause all sorts of
air traffic control type
chaos
run Ryan run run run
Reynolds to okay I have a little favor I
need from you buddy uh Margaret's on
that plane I got to talk to her can you
stop it oh yeah I heard about your lady
Balon drag Ola
Chuck stop the plane please teach you
not to be a drag over right now stop it
stop it no no no come on oh my God
you're going to have to chase the plane
down with another plane you're airplane
Chase come on let's do it shoot it down
let's do it if she didn't love him she
wouldn't have left course am I the only
one getting we got to get Rachel off the
plane get off the
plane R and
Hunt none of them know her like Ryan
renolds does
now no one sees the human in
side Sandy
P Sandy
P what
what oh he came oh my gosh in the middle
of the office oh this is even more
embarrassing than an airport I need to
talk to you yeah well I don't have time
to talk I need to catch a 545 to Toronto
I need the box to go out today I want to
make sure everything is Margaret stop
talking
3 days ago I loathed you I used to dream
about you getting hit by a cat and we
had our little Adventure up in Alaska
and things started to change things
changed when we kissed when he told me
about your
tattoo even when you checked me out when
we were naked when we got real nak oh
well well well I've been naked once
before but I didn't realize any of this
until I was standing alone in a barn oh
wifeless wifeless the woman I love is
about to be kicked out out of the
country he wouldn't have put all that up
with all that abuse if he didn't love
yeah for 3 years marry
me a because I'd like to date
you that's a great
line in context that's lovely that's
awesome there's a reason why I've been
alone all this time I'm comfortable that
way and I think it would just be a lot
easier if we forgot everything that
happened no don't go into denial give
him a choice between what is right and
what is easy that would be
easier I'm
[Laughter]
scared very human
thought oh that
guy that guy is really enjoying
this you supposed to get down on your
knee or something I'm going take that as
a yes yeah
buddy
oh damn oh they make it out now yeah do
it in front of everybody consummate this
marriage you two are engaged again yes
yes for real this time for
real yeah a just because one wrong
answer I'm going to take you
down
okay okay fun version of this Trope as
well nice nicely done I like the call to
the song that's right
man when did you first start to date
last week oh is that going well so far
it's great thank you does Andrew use
men's Speed Stick what flavor Alpine was
it Love at First is it flavor or a
scent I loved her from the
beginning iide the bed you sleep
on look hey will they kill each other no
you fair we don't use the word Margaret
around Kevin he still hasn't warmed up
to her oh oh my God Kevin is so she
farts her sleep oh no it's not true
girls don't have that part of their body
no I call him uh puppy pumpkin monkey
Daisy kiddo oh oh no well when you say
you know the position in the
relationship top or
[Music]
bottom he knew your favorite color green
blue wrong white white favorite color is
blue what's her favorite color when
she's not at home when she's not at home
yes I'm a
citiz are you
crazy oh no
raon who are you engaged to Andrew good
got one
no who are you engaged to I'm engaged to
Margaret Tate and on the wedding day who
will be next to
you but is this a game show I don't
understand what this is a fascinating
medly of
moments
that stand oh goodness land that I
love oh my
good if you're listening to this on
Apple
Spotify leave a rate and review give it
a thumbs up do all the things give it
some
Stars you you know how to do how to do
it Absolut love this movie I did too oh
my God yeah no this was so delightful
and like you know I I love a good
romance I'm often sitting here with the
kinds of movies we more often en
enjoying and taking thinking like oh man
would love some romance I can get behind
you know especially modern movies like
there are times when you're like oh cool
this doesn't have to be a love story but
now I feel like we've done a lot of that
so now uh you know I'm always like yeah
bring me some love but I love this uh
cuz uh cuz yeah this had all the like
you know High Jinks and ups and downs of
a of a romantic comedy but it was just
like an actual Romance movie you know
yeah like it followed all of the tropes
of like the run to the airport the The
Strife that happens and like how they
end up falling for each other but there
were so many real moments that it was
like you can't even be like oh this is
supposed to be funny it's like all of it
during the whole time with physical
humor as well as the pacing and the tone
funny when it needed to be and the times
when it was like serious without them
like really Hamming it up it was just so
real especially like the first time that
you know know um she starts sharing with
him in in the bed like all of the things
that uh she likes finds finds attractive
all the stuff about her um and as you
said like that the camera was moving
from one side to the other to basically
change a point of view like that is when
the switch happened I think more so
between them and it was just such a
beautiful like moment and that this
movie was filled with it like when she
was with the grandma with the dress I
was like this is so touching and grandma
in the plain like there are some serious
little
um uh little spouts from every character
like giving these monologues that
normally I feel like in a romcom would
feel like we get it let him just get
this like Trope over with I never felt
like this in this movie never felt felt
all real yeah it never felt like a yeah
exactly it's like it has all the it felt
like reading some kind of romance novel
in that everything was well fleshed out
everything was cons ious it didn't rest
on I mean you know it's the perfect
proposal for a movie you know like oh
yeah the Green Card wedding and you know
this particular power Dynamic and
they're going to go through all the
crazy hinks of yeah learning to actually
maybe like and perhaps even love each
other but yeah it never and not to
slight other romantic comedies that are
more overtly just trying to have fun
being that genre but yeah there's
something about this that felt a bit
different and it doesn't feel like a a
medley of tropes gleefully strung
together like the tropes are in there
but it all felt pretty natural just
because of the circumstances and so yeah
you have you know you don't get too wild
and too wacky it's not like meet the
parents or something where you know it's
going to get gross out or anything like
that um and I love that yeah it's like
you've got her as a Canadian you know in
this position to be deported you got
Ryan Reynolds Canadian actor you know
that's fun is this Sandy Canadian too I
don't know I don't know uh but but yeah
like it's such a you could easily have
made this a wacky or raunchier comedy
but I thought this was just the right
amount of everything kind of cuz you
know like it is kind of steamy at
certain moments but it's not like uh uh
I don't know broy about it it's not like
off-putting or or runchy in that respect
um and then like the little moments of
you know genuine romance feel genuine
and I love the interplay of like when
you can tell she is starting to open up
to him uh and the small ways in which he
you know uh assumes you know a greater
power position because they're on his
Turf now and takes a little bit longer
to kind of open up to her and the back
and forth of the journey getting them to
the end felt really well earned and well
observed and and it never
felt can't think of anything that really
felt like a contrivance because we need
something to happen and the audience
will forgive us because you know as long
as the chemistry is good we're fine you
know like it it never like I was really
kind of impressed cuz there's some
really lovely Direction in here it's
smartly written and uh and like I don't
know a ton of uh an Fletchers other
stuff but I thought this had like just
the right amount of like it's not inyour
face with style choices necessarily but
it's like really nicely paced and the
again the way it's photographed and the
way it uses its settings is really nice
and the way again in some of those
scenes it's visually representing the
changing in their Dynamics I just
thought was like really uh kind of
subtle and and and uh and uh graceful I
guess is is the word I'm looking for
graceful is good yeah I also thought
that in the in the scene where she
drowns because the the writing in here
is so good but like one Trope is like oh
of course she's gonna fall off the boat
and like she can't swim right so he's
got to save her that is a Trope that we
would see and I think specifically with
the direction is what I saw there is
what I really truly liked is that the
direction was like no you can't swim
like you're going to be hanging on to
this and you're probably like Frozen in
fear meaning you can't move and that
moment to me was like so real because
any other director or you know possible
thing of like oh it's funny she falls
off the boat and of course you got to
pick put her back in and like you got to
warm her up and now you got to like you
get to hold her but all of that was was
was just done so grounded and so real
and I love that I assume the direction
was like Hey like you can't swim you're
panicking he's really got to like
basically peel you off this buoy and
then when he does like hold you it's
like you don't you're so amped up and
now you you have no reason to like not
even dive into him and at that time and
need someone yeah some benevolent
yeah cuz in in another movie that might
have been played Just for wackiness yeah
and bigger and broader for a romcom
world and that was so real yeah and and
I love the way it straddled that line
because again so many of these moments
could easily play out in a in a
different tonality but yeah like that
bit where he they're kening toward the
buoy it's like a natural reason you
would swerve and then I had that moment
when she's like strugg Ling to take the
hand off of it to to reach out for him I
my initial thought was well just reach
out to him like you're just in the water
but then I I realized in that moment the
the plot Point hit me and I was like oh
yeah like you said that would be
traumatic and terrifying and you're
probably just trying to clutch to any
solid thing and probably not wanting to
let go and even later on in the movie
where you know she leaves and he is you
know sort of bargaining with the
situation and he's all frustrated now
because he's like spiraled out of
control the situation that he did have
sort of under what felt like a kind of
control is now beyond that for him and
then she is in like trying to deny the
feelings outright and just be like you
know what I'm just going to leave it's
fine like the the way they still had
those very human it's not just like oh
well now he has to go to her and she
will say yes and everything will be okay
it's like I I like that they took the
time for each of those moments to have
they say that like every scene should
have a dynamic and have like a structure
or have little acts to it and I feel
like this movie was good at doing that
yeah uh cuz yeah there are so many this
is the kind of movie that on Surface you
wouldn't expect to rely so heavily on
its actors but and and not to say that
any other element is FL uh flagging or
anything but yeah the actors across this
have you know their natural charms to
bring but also everybody has their own
feelings and there at least you know you
get light looks into the family Dynamic
and yeah you have Grandma who is very
much you know the warm sort of
encouraging presence and then you have
mom who's sort of stuck in the middle
and like you know Dad is wants the best
for you but is being overbearing and is
overstepping boundaries and mom's trying
to hold it all together and and all
those things registered really naturally
and then when they start splitting off
the characters like yeah you have
freaking raon stripping which is fun and
delightful and I was totally there for
it and I feel like the movie earns you
know when it decides to jump into
absurdity
and uh and yeah and that was an example
of something more Fantastical about this
movie that I I am a sucker for that
Trope of like the same guy works
everywhere in town he's got every job uh
yeah and uh and even the guy the agent
comes out and they didn't have to do any
crazy thing where we put laxatives in
his coffee or something like that you
know oh my God like you know it was
classic I feel like this is one of those
movies where I'm like no matter who you
got cast as if you're a character it
seems like every every body got to bring
some of their chops and yeah it's a
great combination of director and script
and it's awesome to see a movie where I
mean Sandra bulock uh has given many
Great Performances and Ryan Reynolds has
two but I like to see a movie again I
miss the time when Ryan Reynolds wasn't
just the Ryan Reynolds of today where
like every role is his particular brand
of of demeanor and everything is kind of
Ryan Reynolds SL Deadpool except
ironically Deadpool cuz at least he's
not beautiful in that role right so to
see him here in a role that yeah
capitalizes on his innate voice and
charm it also felt like he's actually
playing a character and actually in a
situation rather than a movie is
happening around him yeah I agree yeah
and that was just so so gratifying and
yeah I was I got all the things I
laughed I cried I got you know worked up
I'm curious I want to find out is a is
is Betty White of indigenous
Heritage cuz that's one of those um you
know like she goes out into the woods
and she's like dancing with her and
they're doing this like
ceremony um okay so she was of Danish
Greek English and wealth just it's an
interesting choice for that character
cuz part of me was like I wonder if they
did this because because she actually is
or yeah yeah or you know if uh if this
is an element it's like they're in
Alaska so I would have to imagine that
if you're if you have grown up there
maybe there's
a chance a probability that you might
have some indigenous roots to you right
um yeah see like so that's a bit
problematic that she is you know the
character I guess by now standards
versus 2009 like I wasn't seeing there
like I am offended but in in in other if
this was made today I feel like you
would cast somebody with a bit of that
you know Heritage and I like that that I
really liked her story when she's like
yeah my uh my parents they didn't
approve groove of their Union cuz he was
Russian and I forget what tribe she
mentioned but like it's part of the
character it's not like a goofy FR it's
kind of goofy that scene is perhaps I
guess the most Pro the The Proposal in
and of itself is problematic but that's
part of the fun if there's something
that's truly like kind of like oh
interesting again I wasn't upset but I
am also like ah this is kind of like a
way this hasn't aged the best but even
in that today that wouldn't exist yeah
or or again it would exist with a slight
different casting decision without a
white woman probably playing it is yeah
but as far as those things go too it's
like I'm kind of searching around for
some kind of you know criticism in that
I have any cuz everything yeah just it
flowed so nicely and I love that this I
don't know like not that every romantic
movie should be this but this had all
the joys I get out of watching a
romantic comedy but also just like all
the joys I get out of watching like a
solidly executed and conceived film
yeah yeah and and Sandra be like she
always delivers but she really it it's
in the moments where she doesn't say
anything and you know what she's feeling
and she's on the verge of like tears
when or she feels really hurt when he in
the cinnamon rolls with a bed and you
just see it in her face and then you see
it in her face when she's with the
grandma and you see it in her face when
she's coming down the aisle so when you
say like this film relies so heavily on
actors I think like the biggest thing
and I'm a firm believer in it is that
half of your job is done with really
good casting and I think that's half of
directing is being like this was cast we
cast everybody for a reason yeah and
then you don't really have to stress as
a director because you're not going to
have to be redirecting or giving line
reads right you're just like oh these
people I trust them and we can just roll
and just focus really more on the vision
of how you want it to come to life um
which is awesome and I I assume like it
was kind of a breeze working with these
actors and I I like loved it yeah one
too I mean like they just a couple
straight things like I think for example
Molen Akerman is a great casting choice
because you see her and you think of
what kind of a movie you're in you're
like oh I know where this is going and
it never goes there and it lets her use
her natural charm her those electric
blue eyes you know she's she's lovely
but there's never really aside from like
the natural insecurity there's never
really any mellow
you know contrived out of that I think
she's not trying to win him back the
whole time or like secretly in love with
him or trying to like make the other
girl look bad there wasn't any of that
which is great yeah they just
acknowledge it and it's a it's an
anxiety to some extent but then they you
know they yeah they use it just
appropriately and it's a great
combination yeah of casting with yeah
what kind of moment we're in and uh and
yeah and even just the way that they're
two characters cuz also you look at the
beginning and you're like she is
completely overbearing and he is
completely spineless right and you can
see how that is a toxic Loop for sure
but by the end you can also see
especially with her just I thought that
whole I thought that was played really
nicely cuz it's so easy to be lost in
the surface of their you know Odd Couple
back and forth but when she's like no
you have a family you have people who
care about you and who like want to have
a connection with you that you could
actually be fostering and instead you're
just like selling all of your soul to me
Y and so like after that point it just
feels like oh but I can I can see how
Opposites Attract and I can see how this
Dynamic that we started with with a
little bit of emotional conne connection
growth and letting go of certain baggage
could lead to two people who are
actually well equipped to lift each
other up in different ways so like that
was another cool thing I wasn't like oh
this toxicity is just erased out and
they're great perfect people it's no it
made sense how they could get there yeah
and then ending it on the interview that
you know is going to still be a
show I think is is lovely like and
you're watching the credits and I think
that's appropriate because it exists
outside the movie and you're like okay
everyone's getting all the answers wrong
so like you know I don't know how this
is going to go but yeah at the same time
yeah chef's kiss man I I had such a
lovely time with this Bravo like this is
a movie that I would rewatch like that
I'd go oh yeah buy this movie like
seriously I loved it so much I would
show this movie to people in fact too I
saw a thing I can't remember what it was
it was something it was like what's your
favorite maybe it's even just like a
random tweet thrown out there of like
what's your favorite holiday movie
that's not overtly a holiday movie that
just either happens to feature a holiday
or you know is just one that you know
during a family setting you know it
probably go over pretty well and like
this is a movie that kind of came to
mind just now I was like you know what
this isn't a Christmas movie but you
know you're in Alaska you're in the vibe
and it's like it's snowy
and it's heartwarming by the end but
it's also you know it's going to hit you
in the fields too I'm like yeah it's
basically a Christmas movie Just without
the decorations cuz if there were
decorations there it would just be like
oh it's a Christmas movie they just
don't talk about it cuz everything is
like has that like cozy like
Aline like I loved it good job excellent
like Bravo we love this movie we would
share it we also love you so much leave
your thoughts down below how much did
you love it yes and what other romcoms
maybe should we watch I don't know you
know lot of Classics I'm not seen yeah
give us some juice you know we love it
we love you so much get real reject you
know like a t-shirt if you haven't
gotten it already get on patreon do the
right things you know what I mean
Le would approve get together we love
you so much that's all we got for you
and we will see you on the next one bye
[Music]